because I like I was going out with a
lunatic right and it was crazy dude she
was driving me nuts and was dangerous
and weird and she look like the sauce
ghost a mental problems and of course I
was locked in with him I tried to break
up with her I broke up with her she
would not leave my house she didn't live
in my house
so literally the day before I left for
New York I put her [ __ ] outside but I've
been there Donna and I'm like I'm sorry
but you got to go and I had to leave the
next morning to go do that CD and be
interviewed by the New York Times of
sound EF okay that was the big art
section piece on the podcast so I'm red
I'm getting texts during my interview or
the New York Times from her going like
I'm under your deck someone's called the
police I'm outside right now and I'm
like oh my god it was just crazy and
like because I I had to you know I would
really had to call the police and and
tell her that she couldn't she had her
own place right but she had gone back to
the place how hot was she though I'll
put up with some [ __ ] that hot enough I
just was taken with her I thought she
was bright and exciting and funny and
cute she was Ligeti yeah and increase
great like I and I kept the I never knew
what a codependent [ __ ] I was cuz I'm
like everyone around me was like you
know no one was saying nothing of course
Yeah right don't interfere got your
business up and like and I just loved
her and after all that [ __ ] after
everything I went through to get to get
her out of the house and I was going to
[ __ ] al-anon meeting yes I was doing
the whole [ __ ] trip about four or
five months later it I just broke and
I'm like okay lunch yeah gotta do it you
gotta do it back and then in like six
months later I asked her to marry me and
then
John Marc Maron yeah and then it just
hit the wall get idea was just sort of
like one day I'm like I'm done yeah now
like I was on the road and she didn't
come home all night yeah and we were in
couples therapy I'm trying to work this
[ __ ] out
and then she admits why I'm like well
why the [ __ ] would you not come home
where were you she goes I think I did it
to [ __ ] you up and I'm like oh god I'm
out Jeffrey Tim where the actor talks
about how he said he's dating his girl
and he's gonna break up with her he's
gonna break up with her it's raining
it's raining he was out thin very light
he's meeting her at the end of the pier
I think was the Santa Monica Pier he's
walking towards her nobody else down the
pier and he goes this is gonna be tough
but I'm I'm gonna break up with her
because this is this is not good for me
it's not good for her and I'm gonna live
my life and this is obviously run its
course and everything else and she's
standing there and the rain is falling
on her face and she's beautiful he's
like so I'm gonna break up with her and
here yeah it looks there like that she's
standing there and he goes and by the
way chyme Harrington that got divorced
because I go yeah I chose you'll break
up my longtime girlfriend my dad goes
dude in a public place or should I make
a scene you know what you guys love PF
Changs right now yeah like PF just think
PF Changs
you might be the worst breaker upper two
and you do it during a dinner you got
woody he also can't is my father's out
here beside you at the end a PF Changs
and we're are not so nervous like just
do it but just pull the band-aid off and
I go I'll take the chicken lettuce wrap
thing you know this just isn't yeah I
can't do this yes why tell you I Hey I
just it's just not working she goes are
you cuz are you breaking up with writing
no no no God no no no stay with for two
more years when I broke up with her I
literally like just itch I just hit this
wall it was right you know it was the
day like literally the day before I
think or two days before my 50th
birthday and and I just said look I'm
done you you know you can stay in the
house as long as it takes so to get out
you can keep the ring
I'll pay for a storage space for a year
I'll give you $10,000
I'm leaving what a great leaving my SIA
and I I started like I just started
staying at hotels from the hotel app
yeah in town so I'm just going from
hotel to hotel until she gets out of my
house yeah and I remember I was in a
hotel in [ __ ] West Hollywood on my
50th birthday by myself and then Ryan
singer says let's go to Canter's for
your birthday I'm like all right dude so
that's what I did on my 50th birthday me
and Ryan singer Cigna counters that have
waiting for that [ __ ] person to get
out of my face now yeah she's not only
she get out she cleaned the place which
was the first time she ever did that Wow
that this room that I had that she had
her own kind of room first [ __ ] and it
was just this mound of clothing garbage
and nail polish and she cleaned the
place immaculately and left a nice
little note it first that's a nice
send-off that's a nice send-off it's
like a little for a little while but
didn't I just detached I was really kind
of done my girl took all my clothes all
my furniture and I mean all of it and
the bed I was sleeping in woke me up
that was good really oh yeah and then
without the divorce was different I lost
a lot more on the divorce yeah this was
like you know this was I felt bad about
it but they're just like it just got too
volatile too weird and you know when
somebody has a certain type of mental
disposition it's never gonna get better
and I'm old but what was the whole
unmark I'm 56
is there a through-line to what women
complain to you about you because for me
it's not being present or considerate
like I'm too much in my own world I've
gotten a little better like the phone
thing was like this is the last one so
I'm in a new relationship now and then I
was with the painter who I loved for
like four and a half years but we just I
just had time to time communicate
my biggest issue my whole life has been
anger so and like I've been aware of
that and I know that it's the terrible
thing or or thank God because it's why
you're a great comic yeah but but like
it's like I don't know how to
communicate emotionally and I somehow
you know sometimes I get you know angry
but like with the last woman
sir I mean I went out with moon for a
wild moon Zappa for six months and and I
broke up that was very clean it was
again it was just it was right after the
the other woman who I brought you know
and I got in with moon and I used to be
in love with her we had crush on each
other we known each other a long time
but six months in I'm like I was just
sort of like I'm not working sure I
can't do it and it was that clean and
then the one I went out with before Lynn
was a painter and I loved her but there
was no drama it was really easy low-key
you know was a different vibe but there
was an age difference in a world
difference and I just couldn't commit
she was how old 40 but I couldn't make
her laugh I was having a hard time
communicating with say in that where's
onion while I started the weird
realization the realization was like I'm
I've been married twice I got no kids
and I and I don't have to do anything I
don't want to do and I certainly don't
owe my life to anybody so you know not
for nothing and no no harm no foul in a
way I can't do this anymore and I don't
want to work on she surprised she was
and I think she was hurt and I and it
was and I felt bad and I still feel bad
but why do i why can't I try to be happy
yeah yeah if you know that like there's
a fundamental issue here that I don't
think we're gonna overcome I gotta go
yeah you don't need to be a martyr and
now the new another new girl it's a fish
she's like aging she's like my age
roughly a couple years younger and we
have a lot in common we understand each
other and there's just such a weight off
it's horrible to be in a relationship
where you like yeah you know and you
love them but you're still like you know
it's not and I feel bad I guess you're
letting it go on someone but this one is
it's great but because we're so like
then I there's also those kind of issues
like oh yeah you know sort of like are
you just copying me now okay but I have
this new bit where I'm like um I deal
with the anger like I say like I don't
know how to communicate properly
emotionally you know like for instance
like a couple weeks ago I just tried to
start a fight with my girlfriend all day
for nothing though no reason just poking
poking just so eventually she would snap
and I go what's the matter
you know like so so I wish there was an
app like why don't they have an app
because like when you're an [ __ ] you
got a few seconds you know it's gonna
have you like it you
you are coming up and you know but
rarely can you stop it right so why
don't they have an app that you at least
can turn the app on it'll translate what
you really mean when you're an [ __ ]
like like for instance when you go like
[ __ ] you you don't [ __ ] love me then
the app goes I love you very much and
then the other one is like my favorite
is like you you're [ __ ] with my head
you're manipulating me and the apps like
I feel very close to you right now it's
making me uncomfortable well you know
this is this is what makes you special
and your honesty and your I can't wait
to see the specials right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]